I'm now adorn gold I'm the director of
lucky boy and my website is lucky boy
the short guy
it's about a lovesick going to propose
it was girlfriend but in order to do so
he's got to go through his deepest
darkest secret where she's going to be
heavy drama but it's very powerful bias
but it's the first one I've really been
film festival
I have experienced I'm ranking in
feature no I just really here has some
really great people there's a lot of
things I
he brought the sense of what I'm plotted
but it was also when I had great ideas I
took them you know
I had some great mentors so name roberto
gomes really help me and help me get it
and I think it's
well I got it I got her book and and
then I went to hear seminars she didn't
speak toys we were hoping to encourage I
didn't read it and I realized because I
needed to get to the next level figures
across a cheap and maybe some great
feedback
does
the short com
it'll be a page there to email me is
still not quite live
the trailers